Welcome back everyone to be my new eternals
trailer video.
They released a bunch of new footage is hyping
up their powers in comparing them to the avengers.
Like they joke in the trailer you're about
to be the greatest warriors the world has
ever known also explain with the powers of
kit harington's black knight character are
that he gets to the ebony blade.
So if you're brand-new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos were
can have a bunch of eternals stuff happening
really soon because the movies coming out
in a couple weeks.
They're using the movie to broaden the marvel
cosmic universe, the cosmic level characters,
but also set up a lot of future Marvel phase
4 marvel phase 5 story.
Like mutants the X-Men characters in more
major cosmic threats.
Like you saw during the shang chi movie during
the shang chi post credit scene, they just
type a big cosmic threat through the 10 rings
from another dimension of your big fan of
the cosmic level storytelling that you seen
so far in the MCU to be rolling hard on that
heading into Avengers five, but like I said
this brand-new trailer is about comparing
their team to the avengers team, that's why
Kingo's joking in the trailer talking to his
cameraman saying here about to be the greatest
warriors the world has ever known and most
fashionable Marvel is also calling this trailer
the team trailer, like the eternals steam
compared to the avengers team, so just the
funny way of showing how some of the internals
characters think of themselves as being on
a level way beyond the avengers because of
who they are where they come from and how
they were created call him law Captain Rogers
and Iron Man a terrible avengers I complete
them is a big question about who's more powerful
the internals or the Avengers.
Who would win the fight, I will address that
because it largely depends on who's on that
avengers team the turtles of this really weird
bunch of characters in the comics, they've
only crossover with the actual avengers a
couple times and a lot of people have since
asked me to on.
So my other internals videos is galactus the
one that's growing inside planet Earth in
no I don't think that's the case I mean it
would be really cool.
But galactus is a completely different type
of character who was created in the very different
type of way, he's is old as the universe.
It seems that the gonna wait till after the
new fantastic four movie to introduce MCU
galactus in the pico with the more comic book
accurate backstory for his character with
a couple minor twists.
But then the rest of the trailer is mostly
dedicated to giving you a tutorial on their
powers and how their abilities work and how
they're different from each other.
The funny thing in the comics, is that actually
most of their powers in the comics are pretty
much the same they had a change that for the
movie, so they just kind of seem like different
characters in different personalities if were
actually comparing them to the avengers.
Like this trailer is doing their way more
similar to each other than the avengers because
most of the avengers come from very different
races different parts of the galaxy in the
avengers have mostly wildly different powers
in different power levels.
Like you have the ground-level heroes were
just normal people like Hawkeye and black
widow on the team with cosmic gods like Thor.
Whereas the turtles are all cut from the same
celestial cloth so to speak.
And a lot of their passive abilities are the
same issues for the purposes of the movie,
they give them a couple different active power
so that when they're all fighting together
as a team.
Like they have their big Avengers assemble
moments in the trailers.
It doesn't look super boring the passive abilities
that they share art that they're all functionally
immortal, because the way the celestials created
them to have perfect biology they're not human
they're just celestial creations made to look
human, so that they can blend in on earth
during their mission.
That's how you get the people like thanos
who's in eternals from Titan.
Like his parents are internals but they look
very different from the internals that were
sent to earth.
I don't of their in a completely get into
the whole reincarnation thing during the movie,
they might just skip over that because it
seems like if any of them died during the
movie.
It's not gonna be till present day either
all kinds of theories about Salma Hayek's
character a Jack because you don't see her
anywhere in any of the other present day fight
scenes.
Like what happens to her after she starts
talking about the emergence putting the team
together as they say in the movie though there
about 7000 years old when they pick up in
present day they all you celestial energy
cosmic energy is the source of their powers
and abilities.
That's why all their powers manifest with
that yellow energy there are two different
timelines in the movie or two different story.
As part of the story takes place in the past
and explains how they were created with their
full back story is why they were created and
shows them running around the earth as a full
team wrecking the Deviants like and full-blown
Avengers assemble mode like you saw in the
avengers movies.
Thus the comparison to the avengers, then
the other time.
They explore is in present day after the blip
after avengers endgame when the emergence
is about to happen when the team is been living
apart for hundreds of years just living amongst
humans all doing their own thing.
None of them have spoken to each other for
hundreds of years when the movie picks up.
Because for a long time crow in the Deviants
have gone dormant the turtles assistance wasn't
really required is much.
Not counting all the regular wars and events
of the infinity saga movies because as they
explain aeration the judge in the celestial
host may then taken need for all those things
the other trailers have given us a pretty
good idea for what's going on with all the
members of the team when ikaris starts going
around in present day trying to do his own
Avengers assemble 2.0 as you see with all
the other references they make to the avengers.
This is all meant to be a parallel for the
events of Captain America Civil War and through
avengers endgame with the avengers breaking
up for a while, so to speak, a great calamity
happening Thanos in the snap and then them
bringing the team back together during avengers
endgame.
The turtles are basically having their own
version of that it's another world ending
threat the emergence the celestial that's
threatening to emerge from planet Earth and
destroy the planet.
The Deviants separately they're trying to
kill humans in the third threat in the celestial
host aeration the judge coming to earth to
destroy it if the emergence doesn't go as
the celestial supplanted to.
So here we go again just a bunch of other
world ending disasters.
But going around the team.
Just talking about their major different powers
ikaris can fly and shoot energy beams from
his eyes.
Thus all the Superman jokes vision also kind
of has his own version of this except is energy
beams come out of his forehead.
Because of the mind stone or if you're talking
about white vision is the focusing crystal
in his forehead Sersi can transmute matter.
That's what you see her turning the bus and
the flowers turning the dirt into water turning
the volcanic rocks in the birds during this
big final battle here.
She can also communicate directly with the
celestials in a way the others can't that's
kind it was going on during this scene, she's
communicating with aeration the judge getting
orders from him.
Ajak's powers manifest a little bit like Doctor
Strange's magical shields and projectiles.
But Kingo can give off energy verse in smaller
projectiles you kind of see him doing a Hadouken
on one of these Deviants.
Phastos is their engineer, he creates things
like they have the vibranium joke at the end
of that last trailer.
His innate power manifest more like complex
drones Thena manifests that wicked celestial
pole arm weapon Gilgamesh is kind of like
their version of the Holt making more avengers
comparisons he's the most physically powerful
when he's kind of like their brawler like
a tank.
If you want to think of them as a raiding
party.
You can see him reinforcing his arms with
celestial shields around them is a source
brawling with one of these Deviants spray
create solutions kind of like Loki's illusions
and even though she looks like a little kid
all of the internals are the exact same age.
The reason why the celestial's created them
to look different is just to help them blend
in with the people on planet Earth.
This also gets into the idea of what's going
on with Makkari so she's their speedster she
has super speed is pretty self-explanatory
notice the way they visualize her superspeed
Powers to be different from the way that MCU
Quicksilver speed looks in the way the X-Men
Quicksilver power looks.
You can also make comparisons to the flash
in the way they visualize his speed to she's
also deaf she's being played by deaf actress
and they will explain in the movie why she
is adept because by with the celestials create
an to have perfect biology then give one of
them a disability will explain what happened
with that, during the course of the film drew
egg is telepathic in control people's minds
you kind of see him doing that with his weird
little colt that he's living with in present
day when they go to try and bring him back
for the emergence he's kind of like the Loki
of the family.
The true black sheep then even though kit
harington's black knight character is not
an eternals his powers all come from the ebony
blade this passed down through his family
line the blade comes from the King Arthur
Camelot era of history Marvel does have their
own version of those characters.
So in the main MCU universe.
King Arthur was a real person Camelot was
a real place the blade is heavily enchanted
with a bunch of different abilities, but carries
a powerful curse.
It's kind of like a storm breaker level weapon
with many different powers when the black
knight is wielding the blade as long as some
part of his body is touching it.
He can't be killed.
He can also use it to teleport, but is more
like Doctor Strange is portals not like storm
breaker opening bifrost wormholes and he doesn't
need to be touching the blade in order to
teleport he can teleport himself to the blaze
location and he can bring the blade to him.
He can summon it the way that Thor summons
his hammer and storm breaker the blade also
protects them from most magical attacks.
Like Doctor Strange is magic.
Maybe even scarlet witch's chaos magic wouldn't
affect him as much when the blade is on them
can also feed on the souls of people it kills
to enhance its powers.
But this also ties in with the curse that
it carries the blade draws out the negative
emotions of the wielder and the more people
you kill with that the more it fills you with
the berserker blood rage.
So eventually you can lose yourself so to
speak to the blade.
If you've ever read the berserker Mongo or
watch the enemy is kind of like the berserker
armor superpowerful but also kind of works
against you.
If you're not careful if that's why say you
can lose yourself to the blade.
Like eventually the black knight if he succumbed
to the curse he would turn on all the other
allies that he's working with and try to kill
them to for those of you asking who would
win in a fight if the internals actually fought
the avengers.
So the only way the avengers would have a
chance of beating them because they're so
powerful with the celestial technology the
way they're functionally immortal would be
if the avengers had all their most powerful
members on the team.
Like you have to have Thor was storm breaker
you have to have the Holt enough to be world
breaker whole unit that Scarlet witch with
her chaos magic Doctor Strange Captain marvel
iron man in reed Richards would have to be
there and have to have figured out how celestial
energy works and found a way to counter it
with their technology or use it against the
internals but you can still kill the internals
like you can still destroy their bodies.
They also have a lot of the petty squabbles
that the avengers have like they also break
up as a team for a period of time when I tell
you what happened to make last a little foggy
on some like raining down hellfire.
But if you been a big questions about what's
going on with their characters are how their
powers were just right them blown the comments
and I'll try to address them with my future
bonus videos I will get a brand-new Spider-Man
no way home trailer.
Pretty soon probably a Doctor Strange 2 trailer
in the next couple months as well.
This a Loki game of thrones reunion happening
in the internals movie with Jon Snow and Robb
Stark.
I just did a big House the Dragon trailer
and Easter eggs video for the game of thrones
prequel series.
Click here for that video and click here for
my full marvel what if episode 9 finale video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys next one!